I was six when my dad passed away. We
have no much attention from my mom
because that's what she was struggling
with. I was in in my class just
listening to what the teacher was
saying. And I remember this kid being
next to me out of nowhere. He literally
showed me his part and since I didn't
grow up or I didn't have the attention
that I had in my home, I was looking for
on other places. So I went to the
bathroom and I remember that the kid
following me. He started doing things
like sexual movements and I just started
to feel very very confused. After that
event happening, I couldn't take that
out of my head. They started inviting me
to clubs and start drinking and things
like that. I see these drag queens like
men men kissing men, women kissing
women. And I was so shocked. Nobody was
looking at nobody like they were minding
their own business. And I'm like, "Okay,
maybe it's okay to dress up." I bought a
lot of things. I bought wigs. I bought
dresses. All I could think is like,
"Finally, you can be yourself." I
started taking hormones. My body started
to change. I started my boobs are
starting to grow a little bit. That was
not only it like I started having mood
swings. I started to have so much um
gender dysphoria which I've never had
but I starting to hate myself so much of
the way I was becoming and I didn't
share about those things. And then after
that I started doing surgeries just to
look like a female to have the shape of
a woman. I was so obsessed with myself.
Was in a relationship for a year and a
half. He's a straight but within time he
was like okay let's just try it. After a
year and a half passed we broke up
because he wanted to have a kids one day
and I couldn't offer him that. I started
watching videos of trans and testimonies
of like doing that bottom surgery. I
this is my last step. I was about to get
my vaginoplasty and things like that and
I remember the next day my sister called
me and she's like I received Jesus and
just hearing the name of Jesus I was
like what? You know telling me like you
should come here. Jesus is the only one
who can truly help you. And I'm like,
what do I do? This sounds amazing, but
at the same time, I'm afraid because of
what I'm going to have to leave. Angie
spoke to me about like she gave her life
to Jesus. Mom and I don't know why, but
like I can't stop thinking about it. And
I remember just looking at the sky and I
was like so tired of this. If you're
real, please show it to me. Like I I
need you. I have tried to fill this
emptiness with so many things, but I
can't do this anymore. And I started
crying like my I have heavy makeup so I
had like mascara and so like all start
running out. I felt like the the scales
fell from my eyes. I started looking at
myself and I was like I just felt like
Adam and Eve when they ate the apple.
That's what I felt. I was ashamed. I was
like what have I done? I started looking
at my looking at my dress and I felt so
embarrassed. That was the first time I
felt like I was wearing a costume. But I
can see now like I have not gone back at
all to that world. He opened the door
for me to share the gospel because of
the obedience in that moment to say okay
I'm giving you my everything. And God
has been blessing.